in this video we'll talk about cytokines
cytokines are chemicals that helps
immune cell to communicate among
themselves
so this is a neutrophil how does this
neutrophil communicate with let's say
our dendritic cell the answer is via
cytokine so cytokines are simply
speaking their molecular walkie-talkies
let's talk about the range of cytokine
action
sometimes the range could be long and
sometimes the range of action could be
short
so in most common cases the cell that is
secreting the cytokine
is influencing a cell in a near vicinity
and that is known as paracrine mode of
signaling
the cell that is secreting the cytokine
can also respond to its own cytokine
that is known as autocrine mode of
signaling
and in rare occasions the cytokines can
be secreted into the bloodstream and
that can affect a cell Which is far
apart
so all these modes are possible but
autocrine and paracrine modes are most
common when it when it comes to immune
system
so how does the cytokine action takes
place
the cell that is about to secrete the
cytokine would be secreting cytokine
because they have undergone some kind of
stimulus and that stimulus could be
influenced from a different cell or due
to pathogen exposure so anyway this cell
would upregulate the cytokine genes
cytokine genes would be expressed and
the protein would be produced eventually
cytochrine would be secreted the
recipient cell would recognize that
cytokine via cytokine receptor then Gene
or enzyme corresponding to that would be
activated and eventually a biological
response would be evoked so this is a
common formula for all the cytokines
however in different families of
cytokine the response kinetics could be
different
let's talk about the features of
cytokine mediated response
so cytokines can show cleotropy that
means one cytokine
can do many functions for example il4
can act on B cell T cytotoxic cell and
mast cell and that lead to different
different biological response for
example it lead to proliferation of the
mast cell and it also lead to activation
of the B cells which triggers the
differentiation
so many uh one particular cytokine many
responses there could be also redundancy
in this model
a particular cell can secrete different
kind of cytokines which act on a same
cell and lead to a common function let's
say B cell proliferation
that means many cytokine one common
function that is known as redundancy
there are other modes of action for
example there is synergy two different
cytokines can work hand in hand for
example il-4 and il5
and they triggered the B cell response
and they differentiate the B cell into
ige producing plasma cell sometimes
there could be antagonism that means one
cytokine preventing the act of another
cytokine so interferon gamma inhibits
the il4 and prevents the IG production
via specific plasma cell
now cytokine families are six families
interleukin family then class one
cytokine or hematoprotein family
then Class 2 cytokine family or
interferon family tumor necrosis a
factor family
interleukin-17 family and lastly the
chemokai family
now we'll take some examples from all of
these families and try to understand
their functions
and we would put them into specific
immunological context first let's talk
about some pro-inflammatory cytokines
which evokes inflammatory responses we
would be talking about il1 il-6 tnf
Alpha these are the key cytokines which
are associated with inflammatory
response these cytokines are secreted
generally by dendritic cell neutrophil
or macrophages
now all these cytokines lead to
responses like fever or acute phase
protein production
when it comes to inflammation we should
understand the th1 subpopulation of cell
secretes tnf Alpha and interferon gamma
and that lead to sepsis so all these
kind of cytokines are associated with
some aspects of inflammation
now let's talk about the opposite end
anti-inflammatory cytokine
the Hallmark anti-inflammatory cytokine
is il-10 and TGF beta T regulatory cell
actually suppress immune response by
secreting IL 10 and TGF beta which can
be received by macrophages dendritic
cell or even T cells which kind of tamed
down their responses
then we talk about IL two three four and
five il-2 stimulates T helper cell
production and il-3 stimulates bone
marrow il4 stimulates ige production and
il-5 stimulates IGA production we'll
talk about this in bit more details il-2
plays crucial role in th Cell Activation
T Cell Activation requires three
distinct signals the third signal comes
from the il2 mediated receptor
Activation so generally these naive T
cells are in a quiescent stage they
entered the cell cycle after this
stimulation then they rapidly
proliferate and expand clonally
now when it comes to il-4 and other
cytokines which triggers the class
switching we have to understand the B
Cell Activation in bit more details B
Cell Activation is triggered by T helper
cell two distinct interaction lead to
signals that activates the B cell and
allow them to rapidly proliferate
eventually this activated B cell would
undergo Affinity maturation and class
switching response
to give rise to a specifics isotype
producing plasma cell
now a naive B cell have IGM and igd
receptor on their surface but our
distinct plasma cell would have
one particular antibody that would be
secreted let's say the plasma cell can
secrete either IGA or ige or IGM but it
would not secrete all the possible
subtypes so this is taken care of by a
class switching response
so the trigger for class switching that
means which isotype would be generated
is actually dictated by these cytokines
just to give you an example if il4 is
stimulating a naive B cell the class
switching would ultimately generate IG
G1 or ige subtype
if TGF beta is stimulating the naive B
cell it would produce IGG 2B or IGA if
il5 is stimulating then IGA would be
produced in if interferon gamma is
stimulating then IGG 2A or ig3 would be
produced that means different kind of
polarizing cytokine can give rise to
different class switching responses and
producing different isotypes of antibody
now let me tell you the key thing it's a
mnemonic when you have to remember what
these interleukins are doing always
remember the mnemonic hot tea bone stick
and this mnemonic reads like this
hot stands for fever T stands for
stimulating T cell il3 that means the
bone I mean it triggers the bone marrow
ige and IGA Productions are production
is stimulated by igl4 and il-5
respectively and il6 stimulates acute
phase protein production so we can
remember this in this way if you want
more mnemonics you can follow nard medic
anyway different subtypes of tea helper
cells also produce different distinct
cytokines which mediates the biological
response for example th1 subtype
secretes tnf Alpha and interferon gamma
which enhances APC activity which
protects against intracellular pathogen
leads to hypersensitive or autoimmune
responses th2 produces il5 il4il13 which
helps our body to fight against
extracellular pathogens most likely
helmins
deregulatory cell secretes IL 10 which
is anti-inflammatory in nature th17
secrets interleukin-17 and
interleukin-22 which are
pro-inflammatory in nature that means
depending on the T cells subtype
different kind of cytokines can be
produced
so
does it occur to you like how these kind
of different T cells are generated
actually the instruction for making T
cell subtypes are also coming from
combinatorial instructions from the
cytokine depending on the type of
pathogen distinct polarizing cytokine
can trigger the ultimate fate of a t
helper cell let me tell you in details
so this is a starting point in this case
a naive cd40 helper cell
would ultimately terminally
differentiate into th1 let's say or
let's say th17 t regulatory or let's say
th2 sub population but how does one
reach the terminal set from the starting
point
it all matters
how external influences are experienced
depending on the polarizing cytokine
type
they would activate specific Master
transcriptional Regulators for example T
bait for th1 subtype raw gamma t for
th17 Fox p340 rig and gutter 3 for th2
each of these Master transcriptional
regulator would activate a distinct
transcriptional module that would
upregulate genes very specific to that
particular subtype and lead to the
terminal fate so this is how cell fat
specification is also modulated by the
cytokines produced by many immune cells
now let me give you a very specific
example viral infection actually
triggers the secretion of il-12 which
ultimately stimulate the cell and
upregulate the t-bed gene eventually
these cells would become th1
subpopulation whereas helmin infection
triggers the il-4 mediated responses and
it would form the th2 subpopulation and
sometimes these cytokines mutually
suppress each other's function
so il4 would stop production of il-12
and vice versa
now
let's talk about three very important
cytokines interferon gamma which
stimulates macrophages to kill pathogens
it also inhibits differentiation of th2
subpopulation it induces IGG subtype
from naive B cells then th2 population
of cells
secretes two important cytokines
interleukin 4 which helps in the
differentiation of T Cell into th2
subtype
promotes growth of the B cell and
enhances class switching into ige type
anyway il-5 promotes growth and
differentiation of B cell enhance the
class switching into IGA subtype and
promotes the growth and differentiation
of eosinophils one can remember their
function with the mnemonic known as n
Too Proud to Beg For Help
and for il5 I have five Bays
that can show you the mnemonic
okay let's put the cytokine signaling in
a context in this particular context
some of the bacteria pathogenic bacteria
has invaded the body immediately
neutrophils or others phagocytotic cells
such as macrophages dendritic cell would
would reach the destination they would
trigger a inflammatory response and
secrete more cytokines such as
interleukin-12 interleukin 23 tnf and
il-6 this would attract or allow the
differentiation of T Cell into th1
subtype which secretes further tnf Alpha
and interferon gamma so a milieu of all
these a pro-inflammatory cytokine would
trigger a strong potent inflammatory
response this would attract further
neutrophils and monocytes into the site
of infection so now we understand how
cytokine signaling is really important
for inflammatory responses now not only
cytokines chemokines are also really
important molecules for example when
macrophage or dendritic cell engulfs a
pathogen it secretes interleukin-8 or
cxcl which is a chemokine ligand
this triggers
many cells like neutrophils or like
for the dendritic cells into the site of
infection so they attract as if they are
asking for more backup so more and more
cells infiltrate into the area of
infection and try to eliminate the
pathogen and in this process
inflammation is evoked
so now we understand how specific
cytokines and specific chemokines can
modulate the immune responses and how
they can establish communication between
different immune cell types
so I hope this video was useful if you
like this video give it a quick thumbs
up you can get more notes and flash
cards mnemonics in my Instagram page or
Facebook page you can support our
Channel using super thanks if you want
to contribute you can use super tanks
option and then pay via paytm PayPal or
UPI see you in next video